I don't see the American public I don't
think about the American public it's too
it's too large a category for me to
think about what I think about honestly
is what's the best we can do what's the
deepest we can go what's the most
penetrating analysis we can publish and
then publish it and then then the chips
fall where they may and we have a
readership of over a million people
which is less than well less than a half
a percent of the population but it's a
lot of people and and that's what I care
about I I know that 50 million people
are not going to read the New York or 50
million people don't do anything all at
once so all I'm thinking about is to do
what we do and what we do best it's not
a question of snobbery it's not a
question of elitism it's a question of
doing what we know how to do you know in
the when they're first were potboilers
in the 60s Jacqueline Susann would
publish a novel like valley of the dolls
and she'd sell a gazillion copies of it
and novelists everywhere who needed to
make a living foot ok I'll write one of
those and and that will support me for
the restaurant and a lot tried and they
can't do it and we only know how to do
what we know how to do it's not a
highbrow magazine in the sense of Paris
Review in the 50s at its zenith at nor
is it people or us or some it is what it
is it's this The New Yorker is a very
strange animal when you think about it
if you had a billionaire today and you
approach the billionaire with two ideas
for a magazine the first idea for a
magazine would be let's take the most
popular television personality in
America and we will call it after her
first initial and we'll put her on the
cover every month
and the magazine will be an emanation of
her sensibility and advice and the
celebrity she knows and the kind of
earnest articles about women's health or
whatever it may be that'll be one
magazine will call it over Oprah
billionaire nods interesting idea the
other idea for a magazine I have is the
following the cover will not have
photographs neither of newsmakers nor
women in bikinis there will be drawings
they might be funny they might be of a
seasonal landscape and the inside will
have black and white cartoons strange
humor pieces by people like David
Sedaris or andy Borowitz or patty marks
or something fourteen thousand words on
the war in Iraq say or and then maybe a
piece on the scrap metal industry and a
short story and james wood on Tolstoy
and some reviews of current thing and
that'll be that magazine which one do
you think the billionaire would choose
so the New Yorker the second magazine I
described ism is a happy freak of nature
and we're lucky to have it how it
survived from 1925 and kept having
various wonderful periods which most
magazines don't have they usually have
one period that's okay and then they
either die or they kind of drift into
obscurity how this animal has learned to
revive itself and stay vital and
important and funny lively is is kind of
a miracle and that's what we try to do
something that's very hard to live with
and I've asked that question in one form
or another all my adult life is that the
reading of difficult books say is never
going to be the obsession of a vast
majority of the American English or any
other people to spend an hour or two or
three a few nights a week placing
yourself in front of an enigmatic text
little words in black and white and then
you're supposed to form pictures in your
mind or ideas in your mind and make that
your central obsession or pleasure or
entertainment to expect some huge
portion of any people to do that has
always been off base now we live in a
world of many screens I grew up in a
world of one screen the television
screen that was an erotic Laura enough
you know now I have a good witness to
teenagers who are faced with at many
more screens and the laws have become
even more tantalizing and the pull away
from placing yourself in front of that
enigmatic text whether it's nonfiction
or fiction or whatever grows more
difficult more strained more unlikely
and we have to work all the harder I
don't think that just because we have a
couple of little videos on our website
that's going to save the need to be the
salvation of the New Yorker it's nice it
might be fun but there were I think
there'll always be readers I'm not as
pessimistic even as the Caleb crane
peace in our own mag
scene about reading but then I wouldn't
be in the business on in if I average by
worse